let's walk you through the data there
were 29
892 new cases of the delta variant
identified
in the last week that means a total
of 42 323 cases of the variant have now
been reported
90 of all new cases reported in the uk
are now that delta variant and the
latest
risk assessment suggests that vaccines
are 17
less effective after one dose that is
compared with the kent variant
the office for national statistics
estimates that 96
800 people in england had coveted 19
last week that is up by over 10 000
from the week before well our health
correspondent ashish joshi uh joins me
now from the newsroom and uh this is
pretty troublesome
data isn't it not just in the course of
this pandemic but also
for the prospects of that great final
unlock on the 21st of june
yes this data comes just ahead of the
weekend where the prime minister will be
talking to his scientists and
his other advisors and looking at all
the figures presented to him before
he tells the country effectively on
monday what's going to happen
a week later on the 21st of june the
target that he has
set himself for lifting all restrictions
in his country now
we have to remember sam that these
these numbers the surge in cases driven
by the delta variant
is against the backdrop of the most
incredible vaccinization and
immunization program ever undertaken
in this country so if this delta variant
is finding
so many new people to infect every day
while we have a vaccination program in
place then
really that has to trouble the prime
minister
and that's why there are so many
scientists who are calling for
a delay in this reopening
of the country on the 21st of june the
the argument to this
what people will say is well yes we have
a variant people are becoming infected
but we aren't seeing hospitalizations
spike in the same way we're not seeing
as many people fall
very very ill and we're not seeing the
number of people dying
in the same way we were earlier and that
is the the key argument but then
the argument the counter-argument to
that if it as
as it were is that if you have more
infections
you will have more people who will fall
sick you will have more people
who need hospital treatments and if
even if they're getting much better much
more quickly
they are still occupying bed space and
that still puts pressure
on the nhs as it tries to recover to
where it was before
tries to offer up more elective
procedures more
operations seize more patients all of
this just adds to
the pressure that the nhs is already
under it's certainly something
it doesn't need it doesn't need a new
variant driving
a spike in infections and those
infections leading to hospitalization so
a lot for the prime minister to consider